I'd like to hear in your woods just
briefly what you what this movies about
this movie is about parents finding out
their kids or making what they feel is a
bad decision and trying to stop that bad
decision right but really this movie is
about but Chuck oh yes oh yes there's
also that I like to know when you are
filming your pivotal bot chugging scene
did you use a stunt bud or was that your
but there is no way to to equal the
presence of my butt so you do your own
butt stunts I have to I was a massive
casting process we sent out for the
asses of the world and you couldn't find
one
it was just not anything that measured
up to the the ham like substance of butt
meat that I can put on screen and what
kind of preparation did you put your
butt through the training the
preparation the mental exhaustion the
emotional rollercoaster
butt chugging can can ruin a
relationship I mean it it's not for
everyone now as a matter of fact I
recommend those at home you know they
don't try it I would start with smaller
objects like the the cap of a tire that
you put the air in maybe the cap of a
tube of toothpaste
work up to a non non breakable mason
jars and then the inflatable inner tubes
as my last step could you can run us
through how the director prepared you to
K was great all good directors let you
own that work and she specifically said
you know I brought you this far I've
given you the cliff notes I would like
you to just to just own the work so I
was a great Liberty to to chug as I saw
so I probe and really feel out the scene
yes the scene takes place at a high
school party and on the day there were
120 to 150 extras that had to stare into
the jug as we deemed it onset and I'd
like to think that I gave him experience
that anything's possible mm-hmm and now
what they're I mean if you look at the
pros you can then you can scour YouTube
for this everybody has their own
techniques this is a summer filled with
consistent laughter I don't believe in
that because you can push back out
surprises certainly an element you don't
want to be
involved with I think it's mostly a
state a meditative state of finding
emotional oneness where you don't you
don't deviate you get a resting heart
rate almost like um you know
long-distance runners they keep a very
low resting heart rate asked chuggers
it's the same and you wouldn't look at
me and be like the guys got a resting
heart rate at forty six but I I do is by
jogging an activity you do around close
friends or you can kind of do in public
my favorite but jog obviously is
captured on film and blockers because it
was around close friends it was around
co-workers and it was around complete
strangers so that is I believe when you
reach full confidence in your butt
chuggin abilities as the actor the kind
of mental training you went through just
the the straightforward approach this
thing is gonna go in Maya and they're
gonna pour fluid into it it seemed to
work and did you have any prior
experience to this before III at this
point I cannot confirm or deny that
[Applause]
you